cancer is the leading cause of death
among firefighters today the
International Association of
firefighters hosting an event raising
awareness and teaching how to protect
firefighters against what are toxic
chemicals Mary Jane beliesza takes us to
Caesar's Palace where hundreds of
firefighters attended from across the
country
scorching Flames aren't the only things
firefighters have to battle there's
another invisible right proving to be
fatal and the danger is in the very gear
that's supposed to protect them the sad
part is the chemical companies have
known that these pfas chemicals are
toxic going back to the 1960s this never
should have been infused into the
manufacture of Our Guest Edward Kelly
the general president of the
International Association of
firefighters is talking about
poly-floral alkyl substances or pfas
containing harmful carcinogens the
chemicals are absorbed in the skin and
cannot be washed away it can even be
spread in your house if we have our
bunker gear on and we're in your home
that could be rubbing up against your
couch your bed
etc Where Your Children could be playing
this is dangerous for all of us the
fight we're taking on isn't just about
protective firefighters it's living up
to the oath we took to protect you Jason
Burns a Massachusetts firefighter knows
how important this conversation is so I
got hired in 2006 and we didn't ever
hear the conversation pfas I didn't hear
that until probably about 2017. Burns
was recently featured in the documentary
burned which highlights how these
chemicals impact the fire Community what
changed for me was starting to see 20 30
40 year old kids getting cancer and
dying from cancers you know much more
aggressively than they haven't in the
past and I had just lost two
firefighters of cancer one was 37 and
one was 32. uh one was a childhood
friend of mine so it's done and I and I
I set out to kind of ask questions and
be inquisitive currently there are no
alternatives for another uniform Kelly
says they're working with the National
Fire Protection Association to change
that the next step is teaming up with
toxic tort lawyers changing legislation
and successful reform you really have to
hold people accountable for what they've
done that includes the Bad actors in
this case for me the messages and this
you asked what my next step is I got
about 15 years left on in this job it's
about leaving this job better for the
next generation
Nevada Senate Bill 76 prohibits the use
or release of any Class B firefighting
foam that contains pfas materials for
any kind of firefighting training